one of the stars of the new series on
CBS 9 JKL David Walton here on the rich
out shall get to see you sir great to
see you rich this is this is a big day
for Boston sports fans like yourself a
double-dip of Red Sox baseball and
playoffs and don't forget we got the
opener for the Bruins I mean there's so
much going on I was now I didn't even
know the Bruins did you know the Bruins
drop puck tonight Brock I did I don't
know who they're playing but I know that
they okay so you got that I got that was
so one o'clock we got the Sox then for
is the Bruins and then 5:30 is the
Patriots yeah that's it we may have to
utilize the pip on the television yeah I
haven't done that since the nineteen
shirt in picture that's right you know
that is old school now I guess you could
just take out you know an iPad and maybe
stream it yeah or it just seems like
people have so many TVs in their house
now cuz they're like so you just put
them on just do that sort of thing and
it's all 4k and you could see it all and
beautiful how do we get 4k I can't I
just got a 4k TV I get it how do you get
a forte but it's interesting that you
ask that because you're here at the home
of 4k Ultra HD DIRECTV do I need a new
box I don't have a I don't see now you
get into areas of technicalities that
with which I am unfamiliar now you get
it you get the you get the television oh
you just turn it on alright and it's
beautiful people like you it works for
people like me what Charles Barkley
called me out for being bald on Dan
Patrick show here today
not you not a very happy place to live
in but those things happen up so let's
talk about this day Red Sox are you
nervous about the Red Sox against the
Houston Astros David Walton i am i think
Houston's offense is going to be very
difficult to contain but it's baseball
and all this is I'd like to know your
thoughts on this you have this
incredibly long season and then you're
the only professional a sport that does
have a best-of-five to start it out and
it's so arbitrary baseball it's probably
the most kind of luck infused game why
do they do this well you're you're all
you're speaking right now to a Yankee
fan who just went through
crucible of a nine hanging one and done
I know Lyon so right now to use the old
Saturday Night Live phrase I'm exploring
the studio space of a five-game series
this is heaven that they actually have
some sort of a margin for error so good
but I understand what you're saying
that it is it is dicey when it all comes
down to it but you've got two
left-handed pitchers who might be able
to do some business and Chris Sale and
Pomeranz you might have that ability to
to get a game down in Houston and it's
not as if the Red Sox haven't seen
Justin Verlander before um so maybe you
you have a shot look in baseball I think
anything goes you know it's a it's a
it's a lucky kind of game well I mean
last night was a perfect example I don't
know if you caught any of the Arizona
Colorado wildcard games you're a very
busy man but yeah Archie Bradley became
the first reliever in postseason history
to hit a triple why his first caress his
first career extra-base hit happened
with two men on in the seventh inning
and it was one of the most incredible
moments I have personally witnessed in
watching baseball that these things can
happen yeah there's nothing better than
a pitcher ripping one or even hitting a
homer I know and then he's got like this
big thick beard we'll show it to you as
we're showing it already big thick beard
which I know you as a Red Sox fan can
enjoy and then he slides into third base
with the two-run triple and everybody
going crazy and he rips off his helmet
and stares at the crowd with an are you
not entertained one of those incredible
moments that you see a picture I know
he's not gonna sleep for a week
I mean well the interesting thing is
then he had to go on the mound and he
gave up two solo blasts so he gave the
insurance from fact the next inning
which is another aspect of how wild a
wild card one-and-done situation is what
a roller coaster of emotions David
Walton from nine JKL here on the Rich
Eisen show and then the Patriots would
you consider tonight a must-win no I
wouldn't consider it a must-win look
here's the deal we all get up in arms
about September and October it's all
about going three and
January you know and Bill Belichick's
record in November in December if you
look back in the last ten years maybe
you guys have some statisticians here
but it's insane it's mind-boggling
so people are concerned I'm not
concerned T b12 is there - that's the
self but he doesn't play defense is the
issue does not play defense but you got
the greatest defensive mind maybe ever
hmm and you got it I just have an
inkling it's just gonna get better and
better something's gonna click and bill
we trust in Bill we try I like it I
don't blame you for having that sort of
attitude I don't think tonight's in a a
must-win game certainly because you look
at the AFC East and I know that the
bills are three and one but everybody
else I wouldn't be concerned about with
the Patriots I'm not too concerned I
will be extremely nervous as I am with
every game but in the grand perspective
I'm not one thing it's a Muslim give
David his numbers we have a number so
yeah you ask him we have stats I want to
live on another talk show David go get
Tom Brady career record in December
fifty four and ten is that good
unbelievable season he's LA he's won
five out of every six december game that
december game Bellatrix record as well I
imagine yeah oh yeah oh yeah it's nobody
else's yeah it's it's not Lloyd cards
from Michigan I'll tell you that so
let's talk about this show that you're
on nine JKL you're on this show of
playing on much nicer guy than the guy
that you play in Brock Meyer which we
can hit a little bit - yes got a little
bit of an edge walk walk me through and
those who might not have caught the
premiere about your character in the
show my character is named Andrew he's a
brother to the character of Josh is
played by Mark for seniors just moved
back from LA after his terrible
procedural blind cop got canceled and
he's got no money in his divorce so he's
living in our next door to our parents
I'm they're just renovating my Park
Avenue duplex I'm just there temporarily
nice and my relationship with Josh very
competitive brothers and the younger
brother but my mother doesn't love me as
much so I'm constantly trying to win her
love by being a total dick to my brother
and he but but what's funny I'll say
this yes with a sitcom the writers start
writing for you and and they adjust the
character based on what they see and you
may yeah what's happening right now much
was just giving me a bit of a complex
I'm becoming Vayner and more of a dick
as each episode goes so what's happening
around craft service look I'm trying to
be nice to everybody but man they must
see something that I don't so they just
writen and they're getting better lines
for it which is what I guess all that
does matter yeah and actually I got it
this is funny this is a heartwarming
story but my hai is one of my high
school best friends and college best
friends yes is a writer on the show
completely randomly so he's known me now
for twenty more than 20 years and I can
tell which lines are him what jokes are
him right yeah it's um really amazing
his name's Austin are all I just got to
give him a shout out its shout out right
yeah and get ready for tonight man when
you watch your beloved Patriots on CBS
there'll be a little bit of a break in
the action and then Jim Nantz will say
something along the lines of nine JKL
Mondays on CBS at 8:30 p.m. find out
what critics are saying it's the best
new comedy on the number one new comedy
on the number one comedy night on the
number one most watched networks CBS Jim
they ready for that that buttery
baritone although I prefer your ear
buttery Barry sound right yeah Nance in
person I've been around in the Gulf
there's something on to otherworldly
about that that reverb these guys got a
rehab earnest chest well he's got he
what he does is he enunciates mmm
particularly well where a three syllable
word comes out as six yes he's a
first-rate storyteller and I love having
them on the show good luck to your teams
today sir thank you it is a triple and I
apologize to the Bruins I totally missed
about the drop it's alright you know
look people are just getting back into
hockey sees are the Celtics playing of a
preseason game that we're unfamiliar
with of all four teams in action
great question rich out of the new
and revolution be playing in Gillette
Thomas have an attitude Raymond James is
that possible we are we missing on
explain the 76ers tomorrow right okay
tomorrow
okay so alright so you only need three
TVs yeah three four kids David Walton
nine JKL Mondays 8:30 p.m. Eastern Time
on CBS come back anytime brother I love
it or happier the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy